si j'ai demandé de venir tous les deux
c'est parce que vous avez tous les deux
les cheveux longs oui parce que vous
publiez tous les deux un livre chez
flammarion et et j'ai hâte de vous voir
parler ensemble de mai-68 tout à l'heure
à partir de 60 si vous avez des destins
radicalement éduquer à dire sur 68 mon
avis non plus at on envie d'aller sur
une émission en bus est formidable et
comment on en est arrivé à écrire les
élucubrations c'est ce que j'essaie de
raconter dans ce bouquin en 1965 je
raconte l'évolution comment un étudiant
avec l' avenir tout tracé change
déraille complètement dérape
complètement et part vers autre chose
sans grande crise un sens rien brisé
sans jamais tirer un rideau de fer sans
jamais craché sur quoi que ce soit j'ai
jamais été spécialement agressif
puis c'est venu petit à petit et pas un
canular au départ y avait un brin de
sincérité par rapport à dylan et à pete
seeger à tout ça où c'était une idée à
toutes les deux perdu leur elle est née
à bien plus tard elle est née un an
après quand quand c'est le type de sucre
s'était donné tellement gros qu'il
fallait quelqu'un de trouver une
explication mais on a dit c'est un
gendarme un canular mais une des choses
que je vous ai expliqué dans la fin de
ce bouquin où on se parle bon je parle
avant tout c'est pas un livre sur les
élucubrations puisque je parle avant
tout de l'année sur la route de
l'auto-stop de la main à travers toute
l'europe et tout mais ce que j'essaie
d'expliquer c'est que c'est venu tout
logiquement jeu gratter la guitare pour
je faisais la manche dans les rues gens
vivaient bien je suis rentré à paris
faisait froid c'était le temps de faire
la manche ouais alors je suis
je me suis mis en quête d'une boîte
touchante et retrouver une boîte 90 un
jeune directeur artistique qui était
inconnu vtt 1 un jeune loup aux dents
longues qui s'appelle christian fechner
ouais t'as bien réussie de rigueur bien
réussi depuis qui m'a dit écoute
d'accord tu fais un album d'abord un 45
tours qui tu fais un album alors j'écris
des chansons et puis un matin dans une
dans une chambre glacée et que
j'habitais
c'était vraiment la bohème c'était dans
un arrêt qui était alors bruno blais oui
un matin je me réveille centre et horner
à l'accordéon à la radio je regrette à
la radio qui s'est passé je voulais
écouter fois qu'il fait tourner chante
tous des choses bien venue de l'été
assise là il ajoute des choses
merveilleuses maintenant et julien s'est
passé je me retourne vers le bio pour
m'endormir et puis ça tourne dans ma
tête je quitte en accordéon patil yvette
g voilà que je saurai cgc a changé les
vingt ans c'est un choix j'ai écouté ce
à l'époque loyalisme à me
rappelle pas antoine ça me rappelle une
fille françoise alors après il ya du
fond qui est arrivé cela fait du mal
quand même non t'as essayé de changer
sinon c'est qu'à taper cannelle celle ci
étant un look un peu plus wen un peu
plus de soin c'est un peu compliqué là
c'est dur de fumer ça en quelques jours
du trou etc il ya eu un tas de
limitation qui sont sortis dans la suite
certaines burlesque est ridicule comme
com edwards ou celle que je regardais ça
que martin britney lutteront a montré
qu'il était du trou ça avait été
construit comme réaction un mois mais ça
va il a montré qu'avec lens panne et où
il avait du talent quelque chose de bien
par contre moi une chose que je voulais
passer vivre dans la haine et
l'agressivité par la suite éternellement
aboutir à scratcher pas ce qui a été le
destin de polnareff ensuite arrivée a
tellement dans la haine qu à la fin du
fini par montrer ton cul à la sur des
affiches et puis et eu fini par quitter
le pays et c'est là que tu as pris ta
exprès d'être gentil des train d'être de
prendre un look plus humain parce que je
voulais être aimé de tous lui c'est là
que rita retraite anticipée couette à
baisser le dollar taxi que j'ai pris un
peu plus tard j'ai pris à 30 ans juste
mais parce qu'entre temps j'avais
découvert le bateau à voile ouais et ça
fait 13 ans que j'ai découvert ce rythme
de revenir passer trois mois tous les
deux ans alors tu reviens quoi de temps
en temps comme ça là je vais produire un
livre j'aime bien organisée et allez
revoir paris un petit jour de quelques
mois ce n'est pas un peu le strict
minimum maintenant surtout fait d'aider
des dix qui sont pas vraiment des tubes
des livres qui racontent toujours un peu
la même chose est ce que tu fais pas
juste ce qu'il faut pour continuer à ta
vie ton bateau ce livre si j'ai que
jusqu'à maintenant six livres qui par
les douanes voyage en bateau se livre
aussi raconte l'époque de la route qui
est au big nique jeux c'est une chose
que j'ai envie de faire est ce que c'est
le minimum moi je pourrais dire que
c'est le maximum alors on parlait de 68
tu faisais quoi en 68 38 g/t tu le dis
toi même j'étais dans les champs dans en
auvergne tout à fait retirer et j'ai
jamais cru à aucun mouvement de masse
j'ai toujours été un des individualistes
et je pense que tout ce qu'on y vit un
individu peut faire d'être utile c'est
de donner l'exemple de fait de vivre sa
vie et puis s'il est ensuite très bien à
toi tu faisais quoi en 68 ont des tas de
choses j'ai même été délicat j'avais un
journal cette élection ses toiles
étaient là
mais je suis pas un ancien combattant
dans finalement 68 donc c'est très bien
mais c'est voilà comme verdun tu faisais
quoi 68000 à l'esprit très individuel
aussi mais c'est vrai que mai 68 ni ne
rien vécu de tout petit avec garage en
68 j'avais 7 ans 7 ans et watts avec l
agent 68
cinq ans et toi tu avec l agent passe en
cuisine un an
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu